there's nothing cooler than Uncle Jesse
shades except the coolest cooler
featuring a USB charger bottle opener
waterproof wireless speakers and a
blender this is episode 44 of lose hit
the road with guest partners
let come in seven different flavors each
and a hand court and wax-sealed
apothecary bottle but only one hot sauce
is bacon hot sauce wash that down like
an optimist with a half-full pint glass
Jill two puzzling perfection in this
Rubik's Cube fridge that actually has a
warm and a cool setting for keeping your
food warm or cold
if that doesn't blow you away use the
hurricane to candless air system that
blows air over 200 miles per hour
without any chemicals greenhouse gases
frostbite or explosions just charge the
battery and blow yourself up a giant
inflatable rubber ducky swim with your
ducky and listen to music with the
Neptune underwater mp3 player that uses
bone conduction audio transmission to
transmit audio through your cheek bone
and into your inner ear and it holds
four gigs or about a thousand songs
cheeseburger mask for some incredible
masks check out composite effects they
have professionally sculpted silicone
masks and gloves and their mask lab lets
you customize and test your ideas from
skin color and hair styles to the scars
burns and paint masks the odor of your
bathroom business with the poopourri
craftsman gift set it has essential oils
that you spray on the toilet water
before you go trapping the odor without
any harsh chemicals odor yourself a deck
of x-ray cards to finally see through
your poker opponent see everything
bright and smart with the ember light a
device that allows you to control any
dimmable bulb with your smart phone the
automated lighting can turn on when you
enter a room be set as an alarm or be
controlled remotely if you're out of the
house and left on the lights camera
action with your cardboard smartphone
projector that turns youtube videos like
this one into grand cinematic events to
improve sound quality while staying warm
the audio engineers hoodie features
acoustically transparent speaker cloth
hood panels and a headphone pass-through
for internal wiring finally go camping
with wires thanks to these solar-powered
tents allow you to charge your devices
while at festivals or amongst wildlife
in the great outdoors like the sloth the
cutest of the deadly sins and as always
thanks for watching
you